depuis le cap et je suis reçu pas mal de
couverture médiatique et formera par un
entrepreneur qui lance une start up
je suis maman paru à la télé c'est par
médaillables d'apparaître à la télé mon
application sap à l'euro à tchoyi et
comme si ces cris ça permet aux sourds
comme moi de pouvoir téléphoner
car on ne fait rien qu'en france il ya
plus de 500 milles sur profond qui ne
peuvent pas téléphoner
cette application utilise la
reconnaissance vocale comme cette vidéo
la montre chez l'entente natale et quand
vous me répondre il a écrit ce que vous
dites c'est automatique
c'est instantané et ça marche en
plusieurs langues et parce que partout
les sûr pas s'exprimer à l'oral je peux
répondre de deux façons de vivre ou par
écrit
l'application vocalises ce que j'écris
pour que vous vous l'entendez je n'ai
pas créé cette application parce que moi
je vais téléphoner mais parce que vous
vous utilisez le téléphone
le médecin a tranché rendez vous par
téléphone le resteront 3 ces
réservations qu'au téléphone et ma mère
à la dore prendre de mes nouvelles par
téléphone
cette application c'est un pont un lien
de plus entre nous ça ouvre le champ des
possibles c'est ça la force de
l'innovation et de la communication mais
ça ne suffit pas ni rien qui vous choque
dans cette image là moi si je ne souffre
pas de curiosité je suis sourd je ne
suis pas une condition médicale
ambulantes ou déficients ou infirme
je vais bien je vous assure ne pas que
cette émission là bizarrement quand je
lis la presse anglophone sur des
articles the watch voice je n'ai pas ce
sentiment là il ya quelque chose dans la
façon dont on parle du handicap en
général en france qui me gêne quand les
expressions fournir systématique entre
une personne un être une condition
médicale ce qu'on a encore du chemin à
faire entre la perception des angles et
la réalité les autres ce n'est pas du
politiquement correct
regardons les choses en face nous à bras
le petit nachoff je suis sourd
car oui pour que l'innovation et du sens
faut qu'elle soit accompagnée d'un
changement dans la société dans le
comportement
j'ai créé une application mais ne suffit
pas de bâtir des ponts de créer des
moyens
c'est en changeant les mots pro changera
les perceptions et c'est ça la vraie
révolution
il faut qu'on en parle alors sa pâle
s'envoler